a third person has been bitten by a  shark within a 24-hour span at a Florida  beach it happened at New Smyrna Beach  yesterday that community is known as the  shark bite capital of the world a  Nashville man was standing in knee-deep  water when a shark bit his right foot he  was treated for minor lacerations on  Saturday two surfers were bitten within  minutes of another at the same beach  none of the injuries were  life-threatening there have now been  five shark bites in eight days guys now  at New Smyrna that is not a title that  you want your Beach to I have to say it  was swimming in the Atlantic this  weekend out of very smooth seas all by  myself really I started here as long as  you weren't wearing any shiny jewelry  and you weren't swimming at night or  dusk yeah those are the things you  should have I know enough to know I'm  okay but still all right thanks Vlad